[Music]
wonderful welcome everybody to the break
room
it's our daily show that keeps you
updated on all the nerdy news you need
to know right uh coming to you live from
our actual break room here at new
Rockstar's headquarters coming up on
today's episode James Gunn teases us
again he's full of teases lately Riri
Williams and Tony Stark's connection and
we talk about Mobius appearing in
Deadpool 3. uh with me to discuss those
topics and more we've got the wonderful
Jay Washington ah thank you thank you
I'm happy to be here I needed to be here
today uh thank you everybody for the
love and shouts out and recipes to my
friend Cassie dang I love you mwah I'm
gonna do my job because you would want
me to keep doing my damn job yeah yeah
we love that you're here Jay Jessica's
here with her with her name on her
jacket hi I want to show people your
name yeah
Brandon doesn't have his name on his
sweater but he's got other words I got
other words on my sweater
yeah and then
I'm uh I'm here rocking uh uh new rock
stars uh merch top to bottom oh you
voted a daily yeah
I wanted a shirt yesterday
um okay uh just the second half of
yesterday when I had you know what I
mean like you can work to if if you
never wear a shirt more than 24 hours
total anyway did you vote shirtless or
unless you get a picture taken in it
that's what you did you take it off
right when you get to the pool yeah
that's fair actually I I didn't wear the
shirt yesterday but I didn't wear the
sticker yesterday I was like I should
wear it today people think you
I didn't think it out folks I didn't
think it out uh hey let's jump into some
headlines
uh first and foremost
um our our brand new favorite head of DC
films James Gunn of all the people that
have been head of Disneyland
he's easily the one that comes to mind
right now and uh my favorite uh so he
teased uh a DC villain uh possibly
showing up Lobo he tweeted out that
um in a social media post oh man yeah oh
man
um uh everybody's on that social
platform right I don't know what I mean
I thought they were talking about the
shark and then I realized I'm talking
about megalodons
is also a modern metal band that does
some pretty good ones Mastodon is what
the black Ranger used to transform into
a Power Ranger it's all of these
websites
oh my God
that's where your brain goes uh so James
again tweeting out now Lobo
um has not been depicted in any films so
far
um but if you especially if you're
reading comics in the mid to late 90s
like myself Lobo was a prominent figure
right like right around when spawn and
Deadpool and Wolverine and Venom were
blowing up and we're kind of all these
anti-hero kind of good guy bad guy
badass Comic characters are really
popular Lobo was certainly at the
Forefront of that for DC and so James
again tweeting that out does he want to
make something he's the main man for a
reason
I like that he chose is there a specific
reason why to choose that one it's just
like so well known and Everyone likes
him well I'm not yeah and I remember
when Coy was here last week and this
came up he kind of teased Lobo earlier
and like we had a good point where like
Lobo can just be his own thing he's
almost like a Deadpool type character
where it's not that he's breaking the
fourth wall but that he just does
whatever he wants he's also right it's a
bike around the Galaxy he's
Intergalactic which we haven't really
you know he's out in space which we
haven't done a lot of with DC besides
going to Krypton right like we haven't
seen a lot of space characters so it
could be a cool way to get into that
right well also Lobo was supposed to
have a series if you remember after live
actions yes because remember when
Krypton was a thing shout out to the
homie Cameron cuff uh Krypton was a
thing they were doing a spin-off of Lobo
and Lobo appeared I think he did appear
in like one or two episodes but after
that you know that whole thing died out
so you have an Intergalactic Bounty
Hunter for DC who is a bat who's a
badass who drinks smokes and just looks
weird see and James Gunn could do this
and make this everything you wanted to
be I don't know if we put it in here and
by we I know I didn't
check the tapes but um did you
did you uh Jason Momoa was like he
tweeted about it and was like I want to
play him yeah we were talking about this
so we were just talking about that like
hey Jason Momoa you already got the
tattoos and and the look and whatever
and the hair he'd be a good fit but like
we were debating would they let him play
two concurrent DC characters well I
wanna I I don't think there's a harm in
being like let's just get someone new
for this and I'm sure there's a lot of
tattooed baddies out there
what is this the one of the guys from
Sons of Anarchy a lot of people keep
recommending yeah oh the one it was like
the big guy no not a hunter beard yes
yes it's not hunt him not Charlie Hunnam
it's the guy that brand is talking about
yeah and like they were like that's the
dude to play Lobo and it's again it's a
plethora of people out there that they
can pick but Jason Momoa was like just
give me all the checks he was like I
don't care I don't want to be a fish man
no more I just want to do what Arthur
Curry was doing in the beginning of
Aquaman one and that was drink beer and
bars and fight okay in space why not
um so we hope this is like who did he
tease around uh dead man James Gunn was
tweeting out around Halloween so who
knows we don't know if he's planning
Easter eggs for future DC Properties or
if he's just uh goofy shout out to the
chat Ryan Hurst that's who it is Ryan
Hurst yes I know that person okay he is
he's I don't remember him but also yeah
I think I think uh uh James Gunn is just
tweeting out people that he's like I'm
gonna bring these people but I think
he's genuinely also like uh I'm in a
position where I can bring these people
here I'm leaning towards these two and
maybe he's also in a position to be like
I just want to get people hype about DC
stuff that's true and if that's just
tweeting out random comics images hey it
works and here we are being hype here we
are that might eventually damn it
getting bad Mike
um he's been teasing it uh okay and
obviously all week the main topic of
conversation here Everywhere by Panther
wakanda forever
um we're going to see it as an office
tomorrow some people at this table have
already seen it but as we are getting
ready to watch this film and thinking
about what comes after the future after
this of course one question is Ryan
coogler director of this film and the
previous black panther film executive
producer of The Iron Heart series
um they were kind of asking him like hey
what's next for you and he hasn't we
don't know what's next period for him
much less like Marvel what's next but
like I don't think he has any announced
projects beyond that and he did an
interview with variety and he said I
love making movies but to quote a
character in our movie I gave this
everything this movie got everything I
have I'm at the place where I think I've
got this press tour in me then I've got
to sit down and reflect probably cry a
lot because I've been hiding that
holding that back and then from there
figure out whatever's next
um so we were just talking about this a
little bit in the office before where
would we like to see Ryan coogler go
next tremendous Talent so far that guy's
like batting a thousand and like
everything he makes is good and
interesting so like what would we like
him to do go on vacation
take a break he's he's earned it like
you said between the Press tour being
mentally and emotionally taxed not even
just the filming of wakanda forever
everything leading up to it after
Chadwick's passing that man needs to
break I think that's something like all
reporters gonna keep asking what should
you do what's your what are you doing
next what are you going to do next kept
asking Kevin fighting what's Ryan gonna
do next let that man go to some island
with his wife and no cell phone and
chill that's it let him have at least he
has earned a month vacation if it at
least oh yes at least he's earned it and
then oh I said give him a movie that's
not a franchise right that doesn't need
a sequel you know he's outside of Marvel
or within yeah outside of Marvel just
like give him a fun little project
that's not fun Brandon I want to talk
about it
we were saying probably most likely he's
going to want to do something small
maybe do a drama do something like win
him an Oscar or or something like that
like go back to his roots there a little
bit but then eventually maybe a couple
years go by and maybe then he's he's
eyeing that MCU uh blinking light in the
distance what could bring him back well
I mean Secret Wars doesn't have a
director yep but does he we were talking
about that's a big that's a lot of
pressure yeah we were talking about this
before we went again we talked about a
lot of stuff before I wrote does the
amount of pressure he has to put on to
put wakanda together first of all right
to make the wakanda the the Black
Panther suit everything to look like it
look especially doing this movie with
tolacon and everybody underwater now
increase that times a hundred when you
just on a blue and a green screen for
six to eight months with everybody and
you're scheduling everyone out you have
to make sure everyone else and when you
say everybody we talking yeah Marvel
Studios Fox you know they bringing all
the Sony people over that's why they
letting Sony do whatever they want
because they gonna have some sort of
Cameo and Secret Wars you got to deal
with all that let that man get that to
somebody else who want it
okay I hear what you're saying so no
more underwater movie movie in the sky
gotcha
no yeah I I don't know I I was saying
you know what I would like if maybe the
next Marvel thing he does and we know
he's again executive producing ironheart
we were talking about it's kind of been
put on the back burner but uh dorm
Elijah spin-off Series yeah right he's
been talked about for a long time uh
anything I would like more movie Talent
going to the series so far they've
mostly hired people that doing their
first kind of Marvel stuff in the Disney
plus series but I would love to have
like and then they're kind of hiring
people the opposite way right like oh
you did a good job on this Disney plus
yeah now do the movie I wouldn't mind
seeing the opposite direction I went
from Civil War to Black Panther to
Falcon Winter Soldier because remember
she did the five-point Palm Hot Death
thing on Bucky's arm when Sam was like
do you know they can do this like hell
no I didn't know so like I mean they're
bringing I see what you're saying
they're introducing people but it's easy
to introduce through the Disney plus
series because there's not a big risk
yeah the risk is very little as opposed
to a box office 150 million dollar movie
budget you're like hey here's Kamala
Khan for the first time for people who
really won't see it and if it doesn't
make money it's like oh it's a bus but
now people watch it on Disney plus yeah
holding ball game I like that I like it
I mean Mike it's your sending a Super
Chat saying give cougar the storm series
ooh as long as it comes out after the
Jubilee trilogy trilogy
Jubilee's getting a Trilogy three three
Phil Mark yeah
um I've written it uh wow you hear that
Kevin come come come get your boy she's
the only mutant in all three movies too
okay uh yeah coogler uh went on to
discuss Riri Williams and Tony Stark's
Connection in the MCU who's asked about
that he said I don't want to put any
spoilers out there uh there is a
connection there between her and Tony
but it isn't it's it's a complicated
connection and Riri is a supporting
character in this film talking about
wakanda forever but she does play a
major role and we will get to know a
little bit more about how she became who
she is uh when we meet her in this film
and then of course she's getting her own
full series right coming out later next
year ironheart
um but he's hinting at just a little bit
of a Tony Stark connection now we've
speculated oh did she go through the MIT
program that he was said to put the
grant out for yeah don't answer this
question
uh Enterprises I heard Pepper Potts hit
her with a car what yeah okay he's
crossing the street and pepper what was
the texting him how do you get his spot
on
I mean I don't know
oh my God I'm sorry don't sue me here
I'll give you all this uh highly
classified she popped up in the trunk of
the Audi she was like oh what do we got
here how did you know
Gwyneth Paltrow Pepper Potts is gonna
make an appearance in wakanda for you
know all these he was sniffing a goop
candy yeah
no I we need to make fun of her as much
as possible yeah
real quick uh new Rockstar is coming out
with our own vagina scented candles
that's pretty soon uh you'll have to buy
it to find out but uh legit we do have
these enamel pins I don't know this is
just sitting on the table it's not a
formal point
Who's it smells like
to figure that out uh they do have these
why why are you doing like this you're
scratching a sniff like okay
we can't do that anymore Jay we had an
HR meeting about it absolutely the
enamel pins are not scented like anybody
part again this is the Prototype candle
that's coming out later but um uh okay
oh
um speaking of Disney plus series uh
thank God that's what we're gonna
transition out of that real quick uh
Miss Marvel uh we found out this week
scrapped some Daredevil and Jane
Foster's Mighty Thor references from
their finale
um you know they a lot of times the
production designers for these series
like they release like storyboards or
concept art that they've been working on
and the production designer for Miss
Marvel shared some images we actually
have these I think there they are there
you go uh this is from the dodc in the
series and and within there uh there's
uh some She-Hulk characters like Titania
She-Hulk is that Donnie Blaze I don't
think is that what's his name from uh
Hawkeye in the middle there uh the
tracksuit
the sword yeah oh oh yeah yeah the sword
dude yeah okay Bishop Jane Foster
Daredevil is in there that was fun I
would have kept that in yeah I feel like
they cut it out just to be sure just to
be like uh we shouldn't talk about even
though Jane Foster is things like this
are nice especially because it helps
also in the time wise which they will
not it was shared it's on this poor
girl's power portfolio
and fans went into her business
oh Jesus take that down
anything when you work for Marvel you
literally can't do anything because
people like us will go sniffing through
your trash
with the windows down just like
you sitting at a coffee shop and
somebody just walked back and takes a
picture and then now Zooms in hold on
for the [ __ ] it this was not only a
YouTube video it was also an article wow
girl is like just put in my portfolio to
get more work and that Marvel's like
take her off the list
one of the most fun things for like a
protection designer in any of these
films or TV shows to do to be like okay
there's a bulletin board in the
background of this shot
let's go right like I can do a thousand
little things even like some of those
pieces of paper just had text on them
like they probably the wording was
probably fun and interesting right I
like to imagine like feige shows up on
set in just season just start to rip it
down
look at this but who does this but him
knowing Kevin feige he's one of those
people that's like so look this is what
I need you to write in real small print
right here it's a whole Easter egg and
I'll tell you with phase 90 is when you
say because I think Kevin feige is the
one that goes no no no no no no and he
doesn't even think about it he's just
like I don't like this one
and rips them down uh wonderful we're
gonna get to the top the main topic of
this video morbius and others showing up
in Deadpool 3 uh Mobius did I say
morbius
and then I sometimes I say Morpheus and
now we're talking interesting Lord's
fish merch show up morphe is pointing at
Mobius
I mean you know what it is it's a strip
that circles around
um
don't know uh but first we want to shout
out uh folks helping us bring this show
to you all week long and that's the
Batman audio Adventures over on HBO Max
uh they uh it's out now season two is
out now actually you can listen to
season one and season two again it's an
audio thing on HBO Max which you might
associate with video but we've got some
cool audio properties over there let's
get this great cast Rosario Dawson
Jeffrey Wright uh John Leguizamo uh all
kinds of folks Jeffrey Wright uh who
played Jim Gordon and of course the most
recent Batman film playing the Batman in
this one she'll have to suspend some
disbelief for that but um
I don't believe that this is wait how
dare Gordon be bad man you know that
Beetlejuice was once Batman the same
actor
but this series is really good so the
the creator of this series was a long
time writer on SNL and he stacked the
deck of this cast with comedy Talent
Bobby Moynihan Keenan Thompson uh the
affirmation John Leguizamo some really
funny people and so this show is a fun
mix of like comedic along with the kind
of more serious tone that we associate
with um Batman content uh so check it
out tune in for a tale of real life
death and in Gotham City the whole
season one is already available to
stream and season two is out now on HBO
Max check that out stream DC's Batman
the audio Adventures
season two now
the baddest bird noises noises no it's
not it's a bird but
um it's time for our discussion graphic
is there a discussion Graphics
we get to the discussion after we
understand why the [ __ ] do you break
this thing I swallowed a bat
oh there it is I have a Graphic too like
Tommy okay so rumor has it that the TVA
I should look at this camera rumor has
it that the TV the rumor has it at the
TVA and Mobius will appear in Deadpool 3
which is big now this is a big rumor
right big rumor but also if this rumor
is true do you know how this is this is
the connection that they're gonna know
it's not oh okay well do you want to
answer this yeah okay they're gonna let
them do an actual fox Deadpool movie
yeah but his World's Gonna Be crumbling
throughout it and it's gonna be small
little bits incursion yup but he's not
gonna really pay attention to it it's
gonna be things you hear on the radio
little things you see and all of a
sudden at the end of the movie his whole
world collapses is it yeah no keep going
no that was it new his World's Gonna
collapse into the TBA and mobile is
coming out to me some come here wait we
need to talk to you we need to talk to
you he was like why do you look like
Owen Wilson he's saying something like
that is it um so hey it's probably gonna
be because how Deadpool 2 ended with him
jumping through time with Cable's new
machine that was fixed by negasonic
teenage Warhead none of this is in the
script I'm saying this all over the top
um but it's probably because he's been
jumping timelines do we think we're
gonna see his wife because you know how
he do you think he did
I guess what I'm asking is at the end of
Deadpool 2 we see him going through time
doing a bunch of stuff but it seems like
the only one that actually is gonna sit
with us other than that guy with the
mustache that didn't actually die on the
group yeah is that um his wife he
brought his wife back right so would
that be something that you think it's
just gonna be something to see him
having sex that's it they're gonna do
the whole days of the year thing having
sex again again an exact Fox Deadpool
movie well I can see well I was saying
this because I was like I could see him
bringing her back and then being like
well we need to send her back to like
death and they're like he's gonna be
like no uh
tell him that mid-stroke like hey you
gotta let it go away he's like but but
it's happy women's Independence Day I
can't just stop it
I was just gonna say I I like that if
it's and we were speculating right like
we don't know this is a rumor this could
not be true this could be just somebody
choosing to make this up or maybe it's
just like kind of been floated out there
as an idea or if if Owen Wilson the TVA
is in there it could be kind of like
more of a quick Cameo like a silly
justification he's hopping around
between timelines and worlds and like
one at one point he stops he's in the
TPA office and Owen Wilson's like uh and
then they they hop back out or is there
a version of this that feels like Loki
season three right where the TVA and
Mobius plays like a huge role in this
film I yes I agree with the second part
mainly because and this goes into my
second question of how can the TVA
affect Deadpool and cable who's just a
walking time traveler because it seems
like yeah Deadpool did go through time
and jumped and did all these things but
also Cable's just hanging out here and
he jumped from his timeline as well so
what are we doing here like what's going
on here so I do agree that I think it's
going to be a major part with the TVA
because it seems like how can it just be
like so quick if he's gonna now be in
the MCU it can't be they're gonna have
to address him time jumping a lot well
then there's also the idea that you know
the X-Men their series did a lot of time
manipulation right Days of Future Past
so uh is it a situation where the Fox
movie timelines exist within the MCU in
a weird way and we're part of he who
remains timeline and the reason why the
TVA wasn't getting involved was because
it was fine it was just like let those
things happen over here it's part of
keeping Kang out all that weird stuff
because the TVA that we know from Loki
was not it was all Bs right it was
really just a means of keeping out Kang
right it wasn't about preserving some
sort of sacred timeline it was just like
a protective thing so is this
uh what was Deadpool allowed to do what
he did was uh uh the expert allowed to
do what they did because it was part of
he who remains thing I don't know it's
very mind-bending what is this Saga
called the Multiverse Saga right it's a
Multiverse thing again yeah everything
was allowed to play out the way it
played out he's again I think the best
way you do Deadpool is let Deadpool be
Deadpool let his world be his world
don't try to all of a sudden make it an
MCU movie Let It Be That Fox movie and
play itself all the way out towards the
end and towards the end it's going to
turn into an emcee that he he jumped
into the MCU not the movie changes
yeah that's where I'm a little nervous
because I'm like and it kind of sucks
that she all came out first I'm like you
guys can't just mimic exactly what
happened in She-Hulk
is tough but that's been the stuff
if they jump out and then they go into
Disney Studios and jump through and
they're like doing that yeah did it
exactly you've been in the realities
have like Deadpool and She-Hulk they
break the fourth wall and they come out
right She-Hulk goes to Disney Studios
and goes he goes to see k-e-v-i-n uh
Deadpool comes out and he kills Ryan
Reynolds they actually haven't broken
the fourth wall they're still trapped
within a false reality so I don't know
if there's like if they would ever
acknowledge that part of it or he comes
out at Fox he comes out the box and it's
like all of a sudden a fox lot is shut
up
it's just James Cameron running the
place it's just things it's like yo
we've moved to Disney yeah and his last
words are what the [ __ ]
and they're like left him behind almost
like Home Alone where it was like yes
and they're like yeah we can't let you
on the lot sir
do you think um because of this new
movie and I know this is kind of
straying away from Mobius but I promise
it it'll tie in we'll loop back into it
will we see any other mutants like from
Marvel I guess because we've our you
there's so many people in Five like well
no there's only there's Miss Marvel
and no more
that are officially mutants in the MCU
that are announced yeah okay so then no
there's enough no one in chihulk uh well
I guess uh uh some of the people in that
like group meeting were mutants in the
comics they never said it no but no one
down there was not set at all and the
shoes he had that uh plug had in the
animation and one of the uh post credit
scenes right it shows that the X-Men
exists Deadpool exists everyone
literally said I'm a mutant no maybe not
they haven't said mutants yeah at all he
said remember Bruno said mutation so
capital m u do you think they'll I know
that at this kind of so we ended
Deadpool 2 with Colossus kind of trying
to create the X-Men again and also
having the school do you think we're
gonna see more people like even around
kamala's age and maybe Kamal even knows
come into the Deadpool property as
students for Colossus I mean I I love
the idea of that it's not self-aware
Deadpool is like oh the mcu's claim
immune's yeah yeah yeah yeah I think
he's gonna start naming them and they'll
just start walking by yes he's like
these are mine I'm making other movies
so you guys are gonna prove
I'm expecting because once negasonic
teenage Warhead Warhead and her
girlfriend come in it's like yeah we're
mutants and it's like oh kamala's just
like I'm immune I'm not alone it's like
we have a school like we have a place
it'll be interesting they've been so
careful with mutants right even when we
see Professor X in Multiverse of Madness
right he doesn't really say that
language he doesn't talk about any other
mutants that aren't uh Scarlet Witch
right like it would be wild if this is
how they dump a bunch of the known X-Men
characters on us okay so that's how it
Loops this is how it's looking back to
Mobius do you think of Mobius well the
TVA will allow it because is our is this
TVA going to be the TVA that is affected
post Kang so like Kang they have the
King sculpture they're like they don't
remember all of Loki season one
um I assume it's probably gonna be after
Loki season two but it's like are they
gonna allow a bunch of mutants until
just like kind of jump into their time I
think that's like private they can't
stop Deadpool he has way more power more
than them in a lot of ways yeah and I
hope he does show up at the MSU and he
sees the Scarlet Witch he's like she's a
mutant and the TVA at this point right
now is just like damage control for the
Multiverse yeah but they don't have any
real power anymore because now they're
all realizing everything's a lie that's
right Moby has believed he believes in
something that's a lie the sacred
timeline is a lie it's like you said
it's all about keeping one dude at Bay
yeah and now he's just like well I gotta
fix things it's like you can't fix
everything so now you're just seeing
what things are we could again we
talking about a whole different level of
things like when you say incursions we
could get clear and Doctor Strange
somewhere oh oh my God that is true and
Mobius could be going to Deadpool to
bring him in to be like hey we need you
to come destroy the TV have him go kill
the whole Fox Universe quite honestly
just let him off Jennifer Lawrence in
like a half third blue paint because she
don't want to put no more blue paint on
Perfection oh my gosh
I'm just gonna say I wonder only because
based on because what we really want is
we all love those first two Deadpool
movies we want more of that right and I
will say in both those movies when it
got super meta or whatever there's a
little bit of talking to the camera
throughout those movies but like it was
that kind of end of Deadpool 2 is when
it got really I don't know that that's
going to be a fundamental part of
Deadpool 3 because like I think it's
mostly gonna be like Hugh Jackman and
Ryan Reynolds buddy right pick you know
probably the villain we were talking
about who could be the villain of this
like the Deadpool films have not really
been defined by Big Time villains
there's no like Mr Sinister rolling in
there or some kind of you know Doctor
Doom or something that is Mr Sinister
that'd be kind of sick Well here here's
my pitch I think I think like and again
if we think of this is the third in a
Trilogy we kind of complete the cycle
maybe the last Deadpool movie for a
while who knows
um what if kind of like in that in that
sequence at the end of Deadpool 2 and it
kills like the bad version of him with
the so closed mouth or whatever what if
Deadpool has to fight another Deadpool
oh yeah that's the villain right I like
that I like that but it's not Ryan
Reynolds though that's what I want if
it's another again we're talking
Multiverse all of a sudden he don't know
like there's this dude he keeps hearing
about okay him and Logan hear about
there's Deadpool going around killing
and then Logan is with with a Wade and
they're like what the [ __ ] did you do
he's like I didn't do anything I'm right
here and they're like no Deadpool's out
here going crazy and now they gotta find
the other Deadpool and then you know you
got Ryan Reynolds I'm gonna kill him
like we need to figure out who it is and
he takes it off and it's just whoever
he's always joked about the most next to
what if the other day
is gwenpool or or what if it's Hugh
Jackman as the other Deadpool
I immediately Wednesday really we're
gonna cast Hugh Jackman I was like oh
they're gonna be enemies he's gonna be
the villain somehow and he's gonna kill
him and that's why we're not gonna get
Wolverine again
she should be fun to see like a bunny
movie to see them just going Head to
Head yeah right like so many great
Comics arcs are blank versus blank right
Wolverine versus Hulk uh whatever right
like whatever the whole movie is
Wolverine versus Deadpool
oh yes okay yes yes I want this I want
it completely it would be so fun it's so
fun also a guy that's just heals
regeneratively like amazingly and so
does the other one but it's also like
this one has antimonium claws and this
one has just a sword and a gun but I
don't I just want to see it uh also you
said this earlier and I wanted to go
back to it
um I think yeah they'll be leaving every
middle oh it happens it's in the water
they'll be leaving behind all of
Deadpool it'll be like Deadpool 3 will
be the farewell to the like older
Deadpool and hello to the new Deadpool
Marvel Cinematic Universe but I think
the one other character that will come
over is Domino because Domino will be
lucky and just some how completely jump
into it accidentally and now she's in
like the Marvel Universe and I'll be
another mutant and it'll be like post
credit scene yeah she'll be like how did
I get here because she'll just continue
to live and she'll somehow get a mansion
and live a happily forever because
and she's supposed to be in a musical
somewhere with a dude with face paint
he's been asked
in his winter into Deadpool three and
then you have huge Hugh Jackman and
sudden Foster doing most of the music
man for the film and the movie is
actually just when I tweeted and I was
like oh he said music man's out no
Wolverine
Wolverine was like music
what music man's great but they said
Hugh Jackman's music man was bad what oh
who's saying this
can I get a poem
like that yeah also who who is watched
Music Man on Broadway in the poll uh and
and what is your my wife was there she
said he was uh incredible
mom your wife was clearly mistaken whoa
uh as my wife has reminded me many times
she's never been wrong uh we did ask you
guys if you were on Mastodon uh we don't
know if our with if Anna spelled it
correctly but uh 74 of you said no
that's good to hear that's pretty
surprising that means a quarter of them
are or they're Liars
people right now sitting there watching
this on their phone got us on split
screen like all right what app store can
I use I got an Android well [ __ ] it I'm
out that's me uh we also asked would you
be pumped to see Mobius and Deadpool and
83 of you said hell yeah jet ski
speaking of jet skis have you started
planning your Thanksgiving meal excuse
me what you don't serve your
Thanksgiving meal on a jet ski well I
was raised in Florida and that's how we
have our Thanksgiving meals on jet skis
uh but if you're looking to impress your
in-laws and you're friends with a great
dish don't settle for being the person
who brings the disposable plates and
store-bought pie get yourself a
free-range turkey from our friends at
butcher box that turkey is free oh wow
noises
that was a turkey
crap
they're great they take the guesswork
out of getting the highest Quality Meats
and Seafood by shipping brighter boxes
right to your door they also throw in
recipe guides and hacks to make sure you
know what you're cooking we'll blow the
socks off all your family members at
Thanksgiving uh dinner or whatever you
cook up some meat you know don't just
get meat in a box with no instructions
that's an insane get instructions for
your meat in the Box we here at the
break room are big fans of their
grass-fed steaks and their wild caught
Seafood their scallops are delicious and
man do they taste great the main course
for Thanksgiving dinner it can be very
stressful but don't let that happen this
year okay use butcher box it's offering
listeners a free turkey with their first
order okay sign up today at
butcherbox.com break room and use code
break room to get one 10 to 14 pound
turkey free in your first box that's
butcherbox.com break room and use code
break room we implore you to claim this
great deal real quick everybody uh
through your favorite holiday jet ski
memories yeah oh I oh the first time I'm
a jet skiing I didn't fall once I got on
perfectly and I was going
and it was so much fun make that sound
again
[Music]
I think
you may be asking yourself who who let
this dilettante Brandon be in charge of
mandatory today and it's because our
dear co-worker Tommy Bechtel has been
suspended uh indefinitely for murder for
possibly murder for possibly other
crimes both federal and state related uh
but I'm handling mandatory fun today so
go ahead and play the graphic again whoa
double graphic
a graphic so nice we only play it twice
take that Tommy who is now suffering on
suspension folks
producer John throwing up gravity we
should have left you dead producer John
how dare you that's disgusting graphic I
hate it face six the phase six uh
calendar is it's looking pretty bare
folks look at this bear Beast I mean it
looks great we got Deadpool reacted to
it you know but that was did you say
bear Beast bear Beast can I see the
character one more time please yeah sure
Jay the counter again look it's it's
blade uh Deadpool Fantastic Four
Avengers King Dynasty Avengers secret
War there's a lot of there's a lot of
empty coverage almost two years yeah uh
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna do
a little pitch session okay I want to
hear your phase six dream projects but
I'm giving you guidelines because I'm
not suspended Tommy bechtold who who
runs this this mandatory fund
willy-nilly okay okay there's gonna be
some guidelines what you pitched me this
movie has to be realistic when it comes
to the film rights okay I don't see any
crossovers I don't want to hear about
the Ninja Turtles okay fighting shangshi
okay get it out of there yeah the
Avengers fighting the Transformer I want
to see it but not in this pitch meeting
okay the Transformers are owned by
Michael Bay and he will never let them
go he will blow your ass to the sky
with an explosion anyways uh I also
don't want to hear about sequels to Dead
characters okay so don't tell me that
like black widow's back from the ground
okay don't tell me that Tony Stark's
been dug up and he's reanimated if it's
a variant I'll hear you out I'm not
gonna remember any of these okay
uh uh and I'm taking like Thor five and
strange three off the board no no easy
ones okay uh so pitch me a good face six
project that fits in there does it fit
in between the two and now this can be a
series or it has to be a film I'll take
a series okay and it can't be originally
like an HBO Max property uh like a
Warner Brothers you think you think the
bat the bank the Batwoman movies oh okay
oh I was going like Euphoria but oh well
I'll hear this out it's not ready yet
okay okay
all right let it slide I mean you know
of course I have the Jubilee too always
in my pocket but it's not right for
facex you got also I'm not gonna buy
that okay um I don't want to Jubilee
anything okay I don't want it I totally
ever do to you Jeff oh what didn't she
do okay that's the real question what
has she done where where is she going
okay so oh
so
[Music]
tell me if this goes against your rules
all right so I want to do euphoria
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe for
phase six and here's how we're gonna do
it
hey we're getting
dead we already have She-Hulk amen
okay we know devil born again he's gonna
be dropping draws so I
thinking dolls
by phase six hear me out okay and we
keep MJ and MJ's in school now she's in
college
look at you for you but it's MJ income
it's MJ abusing drugs and he's banged
out by Peter did he like get rid of that
web fluid like oh my God I didn't say
that I didn't say that I didn't say all
that
uh it's gonna they're gonna do Oklahoma
I I will accept it if if if like hope
van dyn walks in is like am I dressed
like cooking okay I've never been
happier this is so small I'm so happy
and then Cassie Lane goes [ __ ] you
better be true
okay
so oh and ashtray gonna be the killer
thank you Nina you
well just you know frankly this is a
strong project I don't know okay
Marvel's ready for the uh graphic nudity
and sexual content drugs
it rhymes with phase six
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna pivot here uh
something that will happen Okay
um a quick shout out to everybody in the
Super Chat Christian unpronounceable
Colin Oakman uh thank you for saying uh
hey to me uh Quentin Bucky Barnes ATL
everybody that's in the Super Chat so
here's my Thing Marvel has been doing
three films a year roughly right uh for
the uh this year next year is three
films that's kind of their average phase
six covers two years five movies okay I
think there's one more movie in there
okay and I think like you took strange
three and four four five off the table
get it maybe it feels like a lot of the
other properties the sequel is gonna be
a series like shanxi we might get a 10
Ring series there instead or wonder man
might even function as almost a Shang
Chi sequel or whatever
um we're getting uh Thunderbolts instead
of a black widow film yada yada
I think there's one big property that's
not accounted for and I think it makes a
lot of sense in phase six and that's a
full-blown X-Men movie okay we're
getting okay Deadpool cracks the door
open we've been they've been hinting
hinting hinting we get a full-blown
X-Men reboot say this okay this is my
thought I was like okay
give me like your your type 5 lineup of
this X-Men movie
um I think they I don't know I didn't
think they're far ahead does it have
Wolverine
oh do we I see the fact that Hugh
Jackman's gonna show up playing
Wolverine in phase six and I don't doubt
I mean he already got a completion of
that story in Logan but if if maybe
Deadpool even ends with like okay Ryan
Reynolds and Hugh Jackman we're gone
forever bye bye bye restart that XX
Series without us
um so maybe we gotta recast maybe we get
uh what's his name Elton John uh
[Applause]
so I got I got something for you how
about this Zach yes X-Men but instead of
a movie I think X-Men works better as a
Disney plus series because one episode
can introduce each character you can get
a full hour getting there to introduce
us to each character where the
penultimate comes together the finale is
whatever they got to deal with and maybe
then that maybe phase seven is the
and they're already going to the same
school that MJ is and it's called The
Sex men yes oh wait never mind that's a
different Universe full circle baby okay
it's a different Universe okay I've got
it's already it's already there and
we're already setting up the Young
Avengers like I'm gonna be the only one
go straight Nerdy with this okay
nerdy because you got the the kids
straight horny sexually I mean those is
really corny oh yours was like nipples
anyway we got the kids from the the
caring and living vibrator then we got
the the spoiled Rich chick chick uh who
got a bow and arrow then you have Miss
Marvel you can throw her in there you've
got you've got Cassie Lane
all you just basically pull all the kids
together all the kids
those are the ones the kid from the
caring and the living vibration okay
scar did you already say scar could he
be a part of that yes with a real
hairline
makes sense
he's rebelling oh so Scar's going
through he's going through a thing yes
he's 17. yeah Dad you left me on this
planet and I was trying to get my
Airlines back my Airlines
so I think you bring all the caffeine
that's the property that we're not
seeing because I think we all keep
thinking you know we know about the
Avengers movies as a whole we know about
Kane Dynasty we know about Secret Wars
but you've been building up the
Thunderbolts again and all of these kids
have been introduced Elijah uh Bradley
all these people you put them together
you have a Young Avengers who do they
fight the Thunderbolts yeah okay I still
think I love that giant and I I've
thought this for a while I think they
were going to change I thought at some
point they might change the title like
they changed the title it'll become
Thunderbolts versus the Young Avengers
yeah yeah which I think would be a great
reveal uh these are all great ideas
folks uh I think they're they're pretty
applicable uh definitely not Jessica
is kicked off everything
what if Adult Swim version to Disney and
then it could Premiere yeah animated
animated animated what if yeah
I like the idea of an X-Men movie but
yeah I'm tired of Wolverine we've had so
much Wolverine I only want to see
Wolverine in a movie if it's an alpha
flight movie give me Alpha flight yes
give me Alpha Four yes let's do Canada
give me the little short hairy Canadian
dude yeah yeah let's do them right but I
love Jay's uh Young Avengers movie they
have these little babies all running
around with powers all right well
Avengers
all right listen do a damn poem let me
hear you a24 would have picked up my
thing I know Jessica I do love your idea
but I don't know if I'm legally
real quick speaking of polls 16 of
respondents saying they liked Hugh
Jackman's music man can you believe that
16 of the people watching right now saw
that yeah
there's probably there's less than
people was like it's just great in
general yeah yeah yeah uh but the movie
I most want to see in phase six is based
on shatter star you all love shatter
Star right
didn't get enough time to vote
stay in line thank you to our
superchargers today we did get a lot of
good super chats uh Christian
unpronounceable did ask who directs the
Jubilee Trilogy
um I say you give it to Spielberg let
him have one
that's his retirement move yeah he's
like I'm doing this I was going to
Sophia Coppola
that's what we Jubilee to be Greta
Gerwig and Sasha Ronan yeah
damn dude come on the show I will not
have it female insertion come on the
show Quentin also said a Super Chat
saying remember Wolverine versus Lobos
disappointing fight in the comics when
they because they fought during night
like crossover stuff they were doing I
don't know did you understand well it
was bad I I do remember that I was also
I didn't like reading Lobo as a kid
because he was too edgy for me yeah
well I like Mr Sinister for all the
wrong reasons
is out of control someone's got to stop
stop the pole
uh uh the MJ 2997 sitting in a Super
Chat saying X-Men No X-Files yes Mulder
and Scully as agents of sword that would
actually that'd be sick wait that's a
great idea I mean kind of what
not completely but it kind of what uh
Captain Carter or not Captain Carter
what was it was a shield not into the
shield the one that she got
it was it was Agent Carter Agent Carter
kind of was it kind of retro retro and I
mean secret invasion is going to have
some elements of that right hunting
Scrolls
let's do a show with with uh uh Howard
Stark and his wife uh Tony's a teenager
during those years right before they die
where they're just having like a bitter
relationship Howard's drinking too much
so the economy's in shambles Tony's
doing drugs in college like sharks
Powers anyway dark succession yeah yeah
um just a Noah bombach
that's what I want to see book your
calendars guys 2024 uh you're gonna see
all of these come to life as part of
phase six uh but we are excited tomorrow
Brandon I get to see black panther
wakanda forever we hope you have your
tickets for this weekend again we'll be
talking about it a little bit on this
show Friday and then we'll have a
thousand things to talk about next week
oh yeah finally Jay and Jessica and
Tommy and other folks that have already
seen the movie will get to share their
thoughts on it openly and honestly
without
I like genuinely I'm not going to be on
the internet for like 12 hours when it
comes out because I'm not ready I'm not
ready to hear everyone's poorly taken oh
I saw another one today I saw you
originally yeah I was like
I'm done fighting we'll only have the
best takes here on new rockstars and on
the break room go somewhere else for
your negativity yeah Fridays Friday's
show of the break room will be spoiler
Central yeah we're spoiling yep the
gates are open so if you if you don't
come out Thursday night right yeah if
you don't have time to see before the
show on Friday wait till you see it and
then watch the episode yeah on Saturday
or Sunday yeah oh you'll still be safe
make sure you like And subscribe yes
grab yourself an enamel pin from new
rockstarsmerch.com
send us a jet ski 4 900 bucks and we'll
get a break room
Cedar with a little cubby one on the
side
and uh Jess's uh spoiler-free Black
Panther walk around the forever reviews
out on the channel now uh Eric's
breakdoor event breakdown of Pandora
will be out on the channel tomorrow fun
episode last night people love Andor
can't stop talking about it yeah uh
check out all those and all the other
great content on new rockstars we love
you we appreciate you everybody have a
great day thanks guys keep it Gucci to
moochie bye
[Music]
thank you